je ne suis pas froide
Elise lucer répondent aux gens qu'il a
disent agressive donc voilà c'était dans
le Potter de star l'occasion du 10ème
anniversaire de cash investigation pour
ce projet de France 2 à la donner une
interview à Télé Star et elle dit les
équipes avec lesquelles je travaille
savent très bien que je ne suis pas
froides pugné à oui mais elle t'a vu
doivent être carré on le doit à noter
les spectateurs cache investigation est
une émission qui gratte ça ne peut pas
plaire à tout le monde donc elle pense
qu'elle joue à véritable rôle elle dit
les gens n'osent plus m'appeler parce
qu'ils sont persuadés que quand il
m'appelle j'enregistre tout et même
pizza 30 oui tu vois
elle veut être au courant des dossiers
sensibles il faut savoir que car
s'investigation c'est bien qui coûte
très cher et c'est à peu près un an
d'enquête c'est un an ouais c'est un an
d'enquête je veux savoir ce que vous en
pensez parce qu'aujourd'hui on est en
train de remettre un petit peu sa
manière de travailler en doute on dit
que c'est le métier d'un peu de voyou on
dit quelle pièce les gens et que en gros
c'est comme quand tu cherches un
téléphone quand tu cherches tu trouves
moi je suis pas d'accord et au contraire
je trouve que c'est l'une l'une des
dernières émissions d'investigation
alors elle elle a fait plein de choses
elle a fait des JT c'est pas de
motivation mais elle s'est lancée dans
cette dernière aventure en tout cas pour
l'instant qui marche très fort et à tel
point qu'à partir de 2016 l'agence
Publicis via l'une de ses filiales a
créé un guide à destination des patrons
du CAC 40 uniquement pour se préparer
aux interviews Lucet c'est pas vrai
tellement elle fait peur aux puissants
au patron donc pour moi c'est le plus
beau César qu'on peut lui remettre c'est
à dire que voilà elle fait des
interviews qui sont travaillées pendant
un an tu viens de le dire ils sont
censés percutantes et elle va chercher
des vrais trucs qu'est-ce que tu en
pensant
cette émission là pourquoi toujours dit
parce que c'est une émission ils ont un
a priori avant de faire l'émission ils
disent bon on va faire je sais pas de
quel sujet Coca-Cola les piles sont
dangereux n'importe quoi voilà et ben
ils vont faire tout leur documentaire
pour arriver à cette conclusion il
change pas d'avis en cours de route un
témoignage qui sera décharge pour le
truc ils vont l'écarter pour que ça soit
uniquement quelque chose bien sûr que
oui
ce que tu dis est partiellement vrai à
savoir que oui ils ont une idée de
départ il leur arrive de moduler quand
même sur plein de points quand ils se
rendent compte qu'ils se sont plantes
qui se sont trompés ils ont toujours
raison sur le
petit moi ce qui me gêne le plus les
enquêtes sont quoi ils auraient des
tombes de process qui n'est pas le cas
ils en ont que 12 pour l'instant mais
oui mais ils ont excessivement
par rapport au sujet en revanche ce qui
est vrai c'est quand on est elle a un
vrai courage ça c'est vrai mais il y a
quand même une équipe de télé derrière
donc elle est pas toute seule les gens
t'imagines pas prendre chez toi il y a
des caméras avec Rachida Dati
un courage à 10 personnes c'est bah
c'est ah non c'est pas vrai que quand on
est véritablement tout seul elle est
toute seule elle dit elle est pas froide
moi je l'ai vu dans des soirées amicales
c'est vraiment sympa
oui dans une boîte de nuit c'est parce
qu'on lui demandait mais dans la vie oui
non mais moi je pense qu'elle mène une
vie dangereuse parce que là tu dis elle
est pas toute seule ils sont dit mais
ils sont disent quand elle est à la télé
mais cette femme elle vit en dehors de
la télé c'est à dire elle est dans la
rue elle est partout enfin il peut lui
arriver tout le temps des soucis c'est
hyper courageux ce qu'elle fait de
dénoncer
génial qui est une vraie journaliste
engagée ouais elle est pas froide dans
la vie moi je l'ai pas je connais pas
beaucoup plus que ça mais elle est pas
froide dans la vie elle a un vrai rôle à
l'antenne
tu vois c'est les méthodes
journalistiques sont les deux snaps
elle poursuit les gens dans la rue
Monsieur Trump monsieur de répondez le
mec il a pas il a pas pris rendez-vous
tu as autre chose à tu vois avant
de chercher tes enfants
en même temps attendez parce que elle
l'aime tu dis tu dis mais si elle prend
rendez-vous de longues semaines arrive
sur le 7 elle dit au mec ça fait 15
jours qu'on essaie d'avoir un
rendez-vous fusée les rendez-vous
maintenant
elle a le pack de Pape place
Saint-Pierre et François François merde
c'est le pas
le pape c'est une séquence à part ils
ont demandé des rendez-vous honnêtement
bien avant
c'est que le pantalon qui accepte il
traîne souvent pour les autres c'est à
dire que lui on lui pose toutes les
questions
c'est vrai que c'est souvent des des
numéros a charge en revanche très
souvent dans le cachette investigation
elle nous explique que toutes les
protagonistes ou les contrecagonistes
n'ont pas voulu s'exprimer ils ont
essayé de donner des interviews des
voilà des contre-interviews des réponses
en tout cas et les gens disent non et
c'est vrai qu'elle s'attaque à des
grands à des puissants donc oui elle se
met en danger parce qu'elle est en
première ligne c'est elle qui représente
l'action moi je sais par exemple c'est
un peu comme les compléments d'enquête
ou c'est tout ça moi je l'ai fait donc
j'ai accepté j'ai été la seule agence à
accepter par exemple de parler un
complément d'enquête je me suis fait
massacrer alors qu'en fait j'avais
ouvert les portes et j'étais là ce que
tu avais dit ça a été beaucoup monté
absolument pas mais alors ça a été même
pire que monté c'est qu'en fait je leur
ai vraiment tout donné moi j'étais trop
contente et je leur ai donné toutes les
informations toutes les réponses il y
avait des il y a des séquences avec ma
juriste elle expliquait tout comment
sélectionner les sites comment on a
refusé tout ce qu'on avait mis en place
pour pour purifier le truc et tout et
ils ont rien montré oui donc tu as
toujours rien en fait ils ont juste
montré la scène où j'ai dit mais en fait
tu cherches à me piéger mais ils m'ont
vraiment piéger parce que le lendemain
ils sont venus après j'aurais dit
revenez de poser une question
ça va mieux t'attendais
[Applaudissements]
un tout petit peu le temps pour
reprendre un petit stylo Voltaire non
pas du tout du tout Françoise Giroud qui
disait les mauvaises manières font un
bon journaliste effectivement si tu veux
des résultats pour passer par la fenêtre
et pas par la pensée voilà donc
Coca-Cola et tu dis est-ce qu'il y a
trop de sucre vous êtes tous des gens
ils veulent dire quoi en effet en effet
on est en train de tuer 50 personnes en
ce moment qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'ils
disent c'est pas ça que je repose c'est
c'est le fait ces méthodes de procureur
ou tu te crois tout permis ce que tu es
complémentaire ça s'appelle enquêter
journaliste de presse écrite
j'étais très bon journaliste j'étais
viré certes
[Applaudissements]